Welcome to the second lesson of Introduction to Data
Science. In the first lesson, we discussed data science at
a high level. So we talked about the skills that
a data scientist usually has, and also some of the
problems that you can solve using data science. One
of the most important skills that a data scientist can
have, is the ability to extract and clean data. This
is usually referred to as data wrangling or data munching.
Believe it or not, some data scientists say that they
can spend up to 70% of their time data wrangling. This
may sound crazy to you, but it's not hard to imagine
this happening. Let's say you have some really cool analysis project
that you want to do. Say, look at a variety of
factors, and figure out why the life expectancy in City A
is higher than City B. Well okay, let's say that all
this data lives on a website. So, you write some scripts
to go and pull this data from the website. Great, but
then you need somewhere to store the data, so you're going
to need a database. So okay, we, we use a database,
we store all the data there. And then you look at
the data and you realize, oh wait, there are a bunch
of missing values, or a bunch of this data looks weird.
So you need to develop some, some method to take all
this data and clean it up. This is data munching. And all
of this is necessary if we want to
answer our original really cool question. Why is the
life expectancy in city A, higher than the life
expectancy in city B? In this lesson, we'll discuss
data munching basics using 3 data sets. One
containing information on a bunch of baseball players, called
the Lawmen baseball database. Another containing information on enrollments
in an Indian identification program called Aadhar, and also
data from the last FM API. Using these 3 data sets, we're going
to discuss the formats that data can come in, how you can acquire data
from these various data sources, and also how to inspects the data and see
if it might have any missing or
erroneous values. Alright, well let's get started.